we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we'll go to our next caller from the 9 1
9 area code caller where you calling
from what's your name and what's on your
mind
my name is the length of Raleigh North
Carolina and a couple questions for you
but first a little bit of thought I'm a
new listener and I'll be subscribing
soon to your show and I certainly feel
for the boycott situation there but um
in regards to gay marriage do you think
that um the Republican administration or
Congress will try to pass any laws
barring it and also do you think they'll
make any changes that to the Affordable
Care Act will actually make a difference
and not an impediment that's pretty much
it okay I'm not sure I understand the
second part of the question so let's
stick with me let me deal with the first
part first and then we'll go back for
that second part I see it as a pretty
low priority of the Trump administration
to try to do something on gay marriage
at this point the real the the way in
which they will try to is with so-called
religious freedom bills and the ability
to discriminate based on sexual
orientation because at least for now
until you get something to the Supreme
Court it's going to be difficult to do
anything about the marriage aspect
specifically when it comes to gay rights
though you can definitely attack the
status of LGBT individuals with
so-called religious freedom bills which
would potentially allow discrimination
on the basis of sexual orientation so
that's part one now what was the second
part with regard to Obamacare I'm not
sure I understood that
well obviously we're in a situation
where they are they tried to just rip it
to shreds and they got nowhere yep but I
just don't understand how they can't
make meaningful change to the Affordable
Health Care Act that doesn't just rip it
to shreds and hurt people that really
really need it my situation is that I'm
a I'm a
very gay male I work at home for myself
I cannot afford health insurance I get
it through his employer a state employee
um but I pay a hundred percent of it and
it is expensive so expensive that it's
hard for me to actually be able to
afford just to walk in a doctor to place
it okay to copay so you know I just
wondered you really think that there's
gonna be any meaningful change or down
the road who will they actually get rid
of it and come up something better well
it's going to I've said for a while that
if Republicans end up unable to repeal
and replace Obamacare they may take the
approach of trying to quote fix
Obamacare the problem is the top
priority in terms of fixing or I guess
the top thing that they would want to
change is the individual mandate and the
employer mandate which are sort of what
makes the entire thing as affordable as
it is and you're pointing out astutely
that for a lot of people it's not
actually even affordable so you know I
worry that if the Affordable Care Act
stays you can set it up to fail hard by
defunding aspects of it and changing
sort of the financial mechanism that
makes it even hold together to the
extent that it is so I think that the
answer to what you're saying is
potentially yes there will be changes
but I don't know that they're going to
be good changes for a lot of people
unfortunately gotcha thank you so much
for the call well then you really ABC a
David and Pat I really appreciate it
great thanks hope to hear from you again